der information im
verteidigungsministerium
ursula von der leyen tritt ihr amt an es
ist die erste frau in deutschland die
verteidigungsministerin wird in anderen
ländern mag so etwas normal seien aber
für die deutschen ist das schon noch
etwas besonderes einen gewaltigen
respekt auch davor weil es in der tat
auch keine leichte aufgabe ist aber das
schöne ist einfach jetzt auch wieder
neue themen zu bewegen und da freue ich
mich drauf
rückblick 2003 die politische karriere
von ursula von der leyen beginnt aus der
ärztin wird die neue sozialministerin
von niedersachsen und das als mutter von
sieben kindern
bereits zwei jahre später wechselt von
der leyen nach berlin
sie wird bundesfamilienministerin sie
sei hartnäckig sehr zielstrebig und habe
einen scharfen verstand so parteifreunde
für bundeskanzlerin angela merkel wird
die ärztin aus niedersachsen schnell zu
einer festen größe in ihrem kabinett von
der leyen gilt als allroundtalent auch
wenn nur ein drittel der deutschen so
umfragen ihres amt der
verteidigungsministerin zutraut es ist
eine spannende aufgabe es ist auch eine
durchaus fordernde aufgabe aber ich
traue ihr zu dass sie das sehr sehr gut
meistert ursula von der leyen kann
unterstützung gut gebrauchen
sie übernimmt von thomas de maizière
nicht nur das amt als
verteidigungsministerin sondern auch
jede menge probleme afghanistan deutsche
soldaten im kampf der einsatz ist bei
den deutschen sehr umstritten sollen
soldaten auch nach dem abzug 2014 im
land bleiben
oder kehrt die truppe komplett nach
hause zudem die bundeswehr steht mitten
in der größten reform ihrer geschichte
keine wehrpflicht mehr weniger geld
weniger personal sechs standorte werden
geschlossen
drei viertel der soldaten glauben die
reform selbst muss dringend reformiert
werden
eine weitere herausforderung
rüstungsprojekte ob es nun der
truppentransporter a400m ist der
eurofighter oder die aufklärungsdrohne
euro hawk sie alle kosten mehr als
geplant und funktionieren nicht so wie
vereinbart
es ist für etliche minister zum
schleudersitz geworden
und ob es ein schleudersitz oder ein
karrieresprungbrett wird das liegt nur
zu einem geringen teil in der hand des
jeweiligen ministers oder der jeweiligen
ministerin
denn die meisten für dies ein
schleudersitz wurde die sind über den
apparat und über probleme im apparat
gestolpert der apparat das
verteidigungsministerium gilt als sehr
komplex und unübersichtlich schwer zu
führen mit seinen vielen soldaten und
zivilen mitarbeitern
dabei hat die neue frau an ihrer spitze
viel vor und damit hält sie von anfang
an nicht hinter dem berg
ich finde elementar wichtig wenn ich
verteidigungsministerium bin ist eine
meiner hauptaufgaben wird sein für die
soldatinnen und soldaten und vor allem
ihre familien auch immer wieder deutlich
zu machen dass sie den rückhalt hier im
land haben und zwar ungebrochen
das ist nicht nur den moralischen
rückhalt sondern vor allem ganz konkret
also konkret dass sie die ausrüstung
haben die sie brauchen
dass sie eine gute vereinbarkeit von
beruf und familie haben das ist
elementar für soldatinnen und soldaten
und für ihre familie
für den vorsitzenden des
bundeswehrverbandes andré wüstner ist
die ernennung von von der leyen eine
riesenüberraschung und ihr klares
auftreten
damit scheint er auch nicht gerechnet zu
haben es ist auf jeden fall mutig gleich
zu beginn mit entsprechenden zielen ins
rennen zu gehen machen die
öffentlichkeit zu gehen natürlich wenn
wir sie daran messen
der koalitionsvertrag spricht zwar
selbst auch von einer attraktivitäts
offensive aber wissen das ist nicht so
einfach
trotz marschmusik die stimmung in der
truppe sie ist mies doch ursula von der
leyen lässt sich nicht schrecken
für so manchen hat die ehemalige ärztin
sogar das zeug zur bundeskanzlerin